[Music]
what no big belly burger it's won a few
perks of living in this time Braddock
cows where I come from you don't care
about that you have questions go ahead
you're not sure where to start
Thawne that is your real name
yeah Bart thought since the day I was
born and when was that 136 years from
now do you know what's happening to me
your latest time jump against the flash
caused a massive drain on your powers
your cells contain no trace of the Speed
Force also your ability to move at super
speed as well as style and time has been
completely defeated you can't
[Music]
Barry Allen
they call him the fastest man alive he
is not
up is down black is white do not get
distracted by anything you see along the
way
to reverse-flash
so much are assumed to be bad it's
pretty messed up
yeah this is ground zero for pretty
messed up I'm a cop remember
oh yeah yes the detective who didn't
know he had a sign you're gonna have to
tell her the truth that I'm the flash if
you are serious about being with her you
have to
hey youtubers is Charlie so new trailer
for the flash season 2 we also got some
confirmation on killer frost death storm
and the reverse flash so I'm gonna start
with the reverse-flash stuff first his
episode is gonna be number 11 so we
won't have to wait too long before he
comes back and it will be the earth one
ubar thought just one from a different
time period from before he went back in
time to kill berry and wound up becoming
Harrison wells that was kind of my
initial prediction
I feel like given what zoom is doing on
earth-2 he would be the only evil flash
to ever survive because at any time a
knee bar thong came along he would be
more powerful he would take their power
so they'd either never be born or they
wouldn't be an issue because they'd have
no powers anymore just like Jay Garrick
so this is eobard thawne that Barry runs
into is probably gonna be pre season 1
meaning that he will still hate the
out of Barry think that to the video
message from the beginning of season 2
where eobard thawne as Harrison wells
was telling Barry you know what I've
realized I don't hate you anymore but
you're still not gonna be happy even if
you win you're not gonna be happy so he
hasn't got to that point this eobard
thawne will still be in the prime of his
hate for Barry Allen the real question
is is which time is he from specifically
in what has he come back to do or do I
know you guys are a little confused
about how the time travel is gonna work
they'll totally explain it in the
episode that is what they created the
Cisco character for he's the one with
the Back to the Future Terminator joke
so you're like oh okay I get it
sidestep to earth too though isn't it
awesome to think about the idea of zoom
running into a future version of eobard
thawne now obviously zoom is changing a
lot of things that didn't happen on
earth one so maybe the eobard thawne
reverse flash was never born
we have no idea but any other flashes
that ever rose up or ever came back in
time have probably been neutralized by
zoom at this point so I'm assuming
unless Jessie quake takes the velocity-9
formula he is the only flash on earth to
right now now I definitely think Jay
Garrick is gonna get his speed back
he'll go back to earth-2 and he'll be
the flash thereafter season 2 and I
think that Jessie quake will eventually
get her speed you know maybe not in this
season maybe in a future season but for
now assume is the only flash on earth -
and I guess you could call him a reverse
flash because technically Jay Garrick
was the good flash Mirth - we really
don't know what's up with earth - Barry
Allen but he could he could have been
one of these visions where Barry sees
himself in
prison-like there's a shot of iris on
earth-2 looking at him in the trailer it
looks like they maybe have some sort of
relationship or something but she
probably recognizes him as not her Barry
my berries in prison you look like him
but you're not him speaking of which
there is some iris West stuff going on
Candice Patton's been posting some
pictures there's a new character coming
through her storyline that's not why
West's like another new character but
I'll talk about her after death storm
and killer frost so moving to killer
frost winter is coming territory this is
gonna be so much fun just walking into
the club and full-blown leather outfits
the producers did this really funny
thing where they used Harrison wells
from earth-2 to explain how different
earth to Caitlin and Ronnie are how you
know killer frost and death storm are
from the earth 1 counterparts Caitlin
snow nicest person ever on earth 1
earth 2 she is going to be hardcore I'm
more excited about her than I am about
death storm but I can't wait to see them
Bonnie and Clyde all over town I think
that's half the fun of being one of
these characters on the flash like you
know you get to tell these really
awesome stories but there's also the
idea that you get to play multiple
versions of your character so you're
really playing two different characters
in the same season but just to be clear
the killer frost death storm episode is
not going to be the exact same episode
as the reverse flash episode though
there'll be two completely different
things and there are a couple of two
partners in the back half I don't know
how many I think there's at least two
two-part episodes but moving into iris
West territory I know everybody wonders
about iris because she works with the
paper she gets involved with a lot of
big stories but she hasn't had like a
huge arc on her own until wally west
came along that's really like her
biggest arc but there's also a new
character that's coming as part of her
storyline now remember when zoom took
down Barry Allen when he just ran him
all over town he killed irises boss so
there's a new boss that comes in
supposedly the way they pitched him is
that he's going to have some chemistry
with Iris now that doesn't mean they're
gonna start hooking up or anything like
that
because like when they brought Patti on
the show they were like this is going to
be a new love interest so when they said
this new character is coming in to
irises storyline gonna be her new boss
they just said that they would have
chemistry
so think more Jay Garrick Caitlin snow
so if you're really into that kind of
stuff iris West is just gonna be having
a little bit more fun without the other
characters like a little more fun on her
own most of Wally West's storyline seems
like it's going to be tied up with Joe
for the
couple of episodes I know the clip makes
it seem like wall-e is upset with Jo and
I'm sure that will come out like there's
probably some deep-seated frustration
like you're my dad how come you didn't
know that I was out there but it seems
like they have a fairly positive
relationship now like wall-e is really
excited to be in Joe's life Joe is
really excited to be in Wally's life so
I think if Wally has any resentment for
Joe it's not gonna come out for a few
episodes like it's gonna take a little
while to boil to the surface but it's
probably there and in case you missed
the talk about the Supergirl crossover
there there's no official Supergirl
crossover happening with the flash it's
just that the TCAs the new president of
CBS was like hey you know we'll see what
happens you know it might might end up
going down but Andrew Kreisberg the
shoulder on the flash was like we have
to figure it out in the next month or
it's not gonna happen this year and when
he said this year he means this season
so even if it doesn't happen this season
they could still do a Supergirl
crossover in season three of the flash
but they're a bunch of hoops that they
have to jump through before they can do
that so until you hear it's confirmed
just don't hold your breath
also don't hold your breath about the
giveaway either because congratulations
to endure' Noah you win this week's
reverse flash ring giveaway also I'm
starting a new round now so all you have
to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
there's actually so much DC stuff going
on next week that I'll probably do a
couple ring giveaways so just be sure
and watch all the DC videos that I post
just for updates on that whole bunch of
stuff happening next week the reason
they're calling at DC week is because
almost every single day there's gonna be
a big DC thing happening so I'll be
doing videos for everything it'll be
awesome while you guys wait for all that
stuff to post you can click here to all
about the Suicide Squad special that's
happening and you can click here to
learn all about the Marvel stuff that's
happening on Tuesday thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight